also sind jetzt angewiesen auf unsere
bundeswehr soldaten wir sind angewiesen
auf unsere elitetruppen wir sind
angewiesen auf die männer die noch vor
ein zwei jahren von der politischen
linken in deutschland als eine bande von
neonazis und rechtsextremen gefährdern
bezeichnet worden ist wir waren ja so
weit dass die einheit die ksk der jetzt
eine wichtige rolle zukommt aufgelöst
werden sollte wegen rechtsradikaler
umtriebe und all dem da war sie da half
es gab ja in der test gab es für quelle
die sind aber aber die haltung
insbesondere links von der mitte das ist
militär militär ist apriori rechts und
eigentlich böse das wollen nur nicht
aber jetzt in der situation in der wir
uns befinden brauchen sie und jetzt
lernen die gleichen leute die sie
auflösen wollten sie zu helden erklären
für mich ist das heuchelei
[Musik]